are we now spiraling into a climate
crisis which cannot be avoided
it is a climate emergency that's
impacting lives around the world
as leaders prepare to tackle the crisis
at the cop 26 summit in glasgow
sky news is launching a new programme
the first daily prime time
show dedicated to climate change
this is the daily climate show and
here's what we're looking at in the
programme
the show will feature forensic data-led
journalism live so there's that figure
right there
where we are at this moment we really
want to put people and we want to put
data right at the heart of the show
even when you're on air you can see the
temperature ticking up all the time
which really brings home
how this is something that's happening
right now and it's something that's
affecting all of us
the show will speak to those facing
climate challenges right now
and see how they're working to find
solutions
hi my name is zambi zambi mate
and i'm the founder of django makers
limited our first
product lineup heavens which are used
for sidewalks food parts and driveways
and hours we produce using recycled
lewis plastic
as well as holding politicians to
account we'll hear from those at the
forefront of climate campaigning
i am aaron brockovich and i am delighted
to be here with you at sky news today
and i have to give you a shout out
because i am damn proud of you
taking on the conversation of climate of
water of this planet of its future
putting it out there so people know
so people can learn hello and welcome to
britain's only daily climate news show
five years on from the paris climate
agreement the daily climate change show
will check whether targets are being met
or missed and analyze how the world
and its climate is changing dan
whitehead sky news